today on generation next we're running
through our book of grievances to see
what sony and
xbox need to fix for next gen so help us
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to this
week's generation next gamespot's weekly
video destination
for all things ps5 and xbox series x as
always i am joined
by xbox expert jordan remain yo
and playstation pro hussein absolutely
undulating with anticipation for new
consoles
here's a look that went up didn't you
there's no way oh i am
constantly undulating i think he's got
some kind of
uh google doc or a link to a thesaurus
yeah it's words related to sex that can
be used
in non-offensive ways
not even 30 seconds into the show all
right
so this week came the news the ps5 might
covering myself just in case ubisoft was
wrong might
not be backwards compatible with older
playstation consoles ps1 ps2 ps3
so this got us thinking and got us to
put together a list of things
that we want to be fixed for ps5
and xbox series x in the interest of
fairness obviously we
we haven't got the list that's just full
of stuff like storage
online updates taking way too long
playstation why is it faster if i put it
in rest mode to download my updates
the fan noises please evan insert the
clip of what my playstation is like
playing warzone
and yeah stuff like patch sizes they're
all the obvious ones so we put our heads
together to think
of things that we just we need to see we
would love to see
for ps5 and xbox series x so tam i'm
gonna come to you first
what do we have to have improved for ps5
so the first things first i think uh
backwards compatibility is huge we're
going to briefly touch on
the kind of newsbeat that happened in
relation to that with ubisoft that you
mentioned
earlier so they put up a a kind of uh
support page
and it mentions the phrases like it says
that their games
will be cross-generational in terms of
um ps4 players will be
able to play online with ps5 players but
then there's some text that basically
says backwards compatibility will be
available for support playstation 4
titles but will not be possible for
playstation 3
playstation 2 or playstation games
obviously
that means for a lot of people they read
that as oh
backwards compatibility beyond ps4 is
out of the question
it's important to would kind of say the
caveat that ubisoft might be speaking
out of turn here they could have made a
mistake
they could have said something a bit too
early they could have just put some
template text in
so there's some caveat there but in
in light of sony not being clear concise
and open
about their backwards compatibility
strategy there's obviously going to be
some assumptions being made that's
partly on sony's uh
kind of fault for that so i think we're
kind of
we should take the opportunity to say
that backwards compatibility should be
an
important part of sony's strategy going
forward they
like i said have said nothing and if
anything they need to match what
microsoft is doing because microsoft is
talking big about backwards
compatibility they're making it
available through either
you know um game pass or other means and
sony needs to follow suit with that
there's far
too many games that are kind of locked
to playstation 3 tricky because of the
architecture
for playstation 2 and playstation 1 that
they need to make available either
digitally
or through using existing disks i think
that's crucial to
people going forward and it's important
as a consumer a proposition
exactly i mean for a long time i mean
after i finished
persona 4 that's what my vita became i
would just play all these playstation 1
classics on my vita
and i would really love to be able to do
that if i'm forking out for a ps5
i don't want to be locked out of the
games that i've bought previously
well i guess i mean i'm not truly locked
out because i still have the console but
a lot of people are gonna be selling
those consoles uh in order to afford a
ps5 so
fingers crossed we get some clarity on
that one jordan
coming to you for xbox so it's
beating a dead horse at this point i've
already ranted about it and was down
voted
all to hell but i'm a masochist i'm
going to bring up this point again
but you were right to do it you were
right
i'm so it's like one of those weird
things that i
i love numbers going up it's why i like
playing games like destiny and stuff
like that i'm like oh yes the numbers
are going up i'm getting the numbers
mason
the numbers we want the numbers mason
that's all we've ever wanted so when
so the fact that xbox has gamer score
and you can watch that like
number go up and i'm just like oh my god
it's wonderful it's wonderful but then
every once in a while
some dev decides to be really cheeky
with their achievements and they're like
oh what if we
uh decided to make this uh like
33 point achievement or 67 or whatever
and it'll eventually add up to a
thousand like every game does
or essentially forcing the player to
complete the entire game if they want to
even
out the number again and every single
time i see that it pisses me off
so much i hate it i hate it
look i'm the i'm right there with you i
looking at achievements every time i see
one that's
an odd number i'm like ah you're doing
this again really
just have it five or zero at the end
please
just let my poor brain be eased
with the numbers but also i mean i'm
gonna add a caveat to this this isn't a
real point but like
playstation trophies really can take
a um a page of xbox's book when it comes
to trophy tracking
tr uh achievement tracking on xbox is
amazing and i love it and you know if
i'm working towards something i'll pin
it in the bottom corner
i would love the other day i got the
control platinum
not a humble brag i used the
invulnerability thing because god help
me i could not be mr mercy
whatever but my final trophy that i had
to get was the
25 adjustment at the bureau adjustments
and i had no idea how far along that
trophy was
and i was just kind of miserable because
i feel like the game stopped spawning
enemies for me
and i was like i just want to know how
long i have left man i've got one more
trophy to get
and then i'm and then i'm it and then
i'm done i can do the dlc so
playstation mr sony sir if you're
listening
please all right tam back to you
so yeah the one i'm gonna mention now
kind of rolls into the backwards
compatibility and it
is combining ps plus with playstation
now into one membership
um i feel like there's gonna be some
advancements in playstation now and it
does work in a lot of circumstances
provided you've got pretty good kind of
uh set up for it
um but i don't think a lot of people are
using it and what better way to make
games backwards compatible
to some degree even if it's not perfect
um
by by you know including playstation now
in your subscription and telling people
all those games that you want to be
backwards compatible you can
play via this subscription service um
and it's part of your playstation plus
online subscription
currently there's no way for me to fire
up my playstation and play metal gear
solid
from the playstation one other than i
think it might be on playstation now but
i
can't really tell i don't pay close
attention to that because why would i
it's like awkward right now and it's a
separate subscription
however if i knew that metal gear solid
or any other random game was on
playstation now and it was included in
my playstation plus subscription
i'm way more inclined to kind of get
involved with that and i'm
perhaps speaking out of turn here but i
wanted to go so far as to say like i
would take a small bump in price for
playstation plus
um if it included a playstation now
subscription not massive bump but a
small one
um just because i know that's an extra
feature like a new tier of playstation
plus where it includes playstation now
i feel like that would be a good way to
kill two birds with
one stone you essentially want the xbox
game pass
ultimate version yeah playstation sony
please
give it do we want to redo that section
because metal gear solid hd collection
is on game is on ps now
objection mel goes solid it's not in
that oh is it not in there at all
yeah yeah oh okay take that you think i
don't know metal gear solid
you think i wouldn't know that i don't
know who do you think you're talking
about
i don't know mel gibson all right jordan
what else would you like to see
from series x what improvements need to
be made so
xbox series x needs a system seller like
when i was a wee lad back in
2013 oh we irish lad we
uh i just i just finished uh psych 101
in college and i thought i was on top of
the world and knew practically
everything um and trying to decide if i
should buy
xbox one or ps4 and xbox one had that
terrible
bundle of terribleness at e3 i was just
trying to decide which
console to pick up and at the end of the
day xbox one had
the exclusive deal that i wanted to play
which was
titanfall at the time it was exclusive
to xbox 360 and xbox one i'm like
okay cool so i'll get xbox one series x
doesn't have
that yet and like i'm probably i'm going
to get it because a it's my job and b
i'm just so in the xbox ecosystem at
this point that they've just
got me by the balls and i'm never going
to be able to get away but
i just got an image of phil spencer
holding
jordan's ball you're never going to get
away from me
just i have a picture of him holding
like a basketball with like
my name on it or something like that uh
but
there's like nothing coming out for
series x that i'm like super
excited to play like there are games
like
assassin's creed and cyberpunk that i
will be able to play
on series x but there's nothing that i'm
like i can only play this on series x
and i'm definitely getting this console
because this game can be played
on series x and i i just would want to
see
something anything like that even if
it's some weird little experimental
thing like
titanfall back on the xbox one i so
when we when we're putting this list
together i put down
ui for xbox and ui is fine lucy
[Music]
you never heard that song um the ui
is fine fine now
fun fact the only time i've ever really
had a coordinated
campaign against me on the internet is
years ago when i said that i didn't like
the xbox one ui
and i like it fine now i like it fine
don't come at me but i just yeah i'm
glad they've changed that and i'm glad
we have that going into series x
so before people say the the ui is bad
no they updated it recently
and it's you know a thing that they
fixed because a lot of the things when
we were thinking of things for xbox it's
like
well they actually already fixed that
like it fixed a lot of this
it's fixed but the performance is still
not great across the board like it's
still
clunky in a way that it's fixed but it's
not user-friendly as well
if you want to talk about clunky menus
i feel like and this is a word that i
know i cannot say
i don't know how to pronounce it because
i've only ever seen it written down i'm
so excited for this
absolutely obsolescence yeah i remember
once
i remember once saying obsolescence and
god piss
ripped out of me anyway planned
obsolescence
the playstation 4 menu right now if i'm
going in between a party to check my
like party to game to checking my
trophies it isn't
a mess and it like it just chugs along
and part of me is like
okay yeah i know that the ps5 is coming
but this is some apple
you're slowing down my device
and it's weird because it happened like
for me it felt like it happened
overnight
like one day for me it happened within
the last two weeks yeah mine was like
in the last month where it was fine and
now every time i'm navigating the menu
i'm just like having such a weird time
and i did the thing where
i cleared memory and you know getting a
fresh restart
so it dumps all the data et cetera et
cetera it just feels like that apple
style like
uh obsolescence being activated all
right let's move on so the final thing
i'll take this one because it's kind of
a joint thing that we would just love to
see
fixed for next gen is like cross
platform
play you should i the games i was
looking through a list of like games
that have fall across platform play
right now and it's stuff like
fortnite obviously minecraft call of
duty modern warfare and call of duty
warzone
everything else is like world of
warships brawlhalla
no man's sky need for speed heat
rocket league yeah like one of our
producers rob in the chat big rocket
league fan it's just going rocket league
rocket league don't forget so it's like
i love that this has started this trend
has started
sony has always been the one who's kind
of been like
about it but i just want people to play
the games where they want to play them
but we can still play together i say
cross play and cross progression are
actually
kind of important this game because like
this has been like the huge costly
console generation where we got like
destiny apex legends for now like all of
these games that a bunch of people are
going to want to
take their data over and keep playing
with all of their friends in the next
console generation
and like it's a bit worrisome to see
that
not all of the games have
that yet and i'm like i i just want to
play games with my friends and i want my
data to follow me into the next
console generation is that so hard maybe
tell me
tell me what's gonna happen to my
overwatch progression
that's that's the real underlying thing
it's like what's gonna happen to my
overwatch
but we have we have like another list of
smaller
grievances dual shock battery life
it's especially compared to the
um the nintendo switch pro controller
which is
i feel like i just leave running for
about a year yeah
um account locking on playstation 4.
this is a very specific thing to me and
tam because we've moved countries
we can't uh play we can't switch our
region on our ps4 account
to uh america so i have to keep a bank
account open in the uk
so i can buy games on my account
um the only other way to get around it
is to have
another account which is an american
account set my playstation to be a
primary and then i can use it on my eu
account which is where all my trophies
and all my digitally purchased games are
just make it easy make it like bloody
xbox do it and also save data is like
regionally locked in a lot of cases so
like my sakura
save my sakura
to review on a us version of the game
because
that was the one that was available
earliest and you want to play from
software games as early as possible if
you wanna if you're reviewing them and
then
i like obviously don't have any trophies
for it because on my main account i
don't know so i own two versions of
sakura
um and like it's a nightmare listen i
hate it
my my sakura so i played it for like
three hours in my bedroom on my eu ps4
i went into the living room and played
it on greg's american ps4
it locked my account it locked my save
and i lost
like six to ten hours of progression i
hate to see it and i had to play it
again
but the second time i played it i was an
absolute god
at that game so you know maybe it was
just playstation just teaching me
a lesson all right those are our
grievances
i i just like the idea of having a book
of grievances honestly i might star one
i know i like how you intro this i'm
like do we just have like a tome that
has like everything that
he just wants fixed written down it's
like this like notebook
it's like the book from near it's alive
the grimoire
and it just like constantly eats your
grievances and
moans about it one other one uh
small power on buttons so yeah get a
grip
fun fact the one of the times i've had a
targeted hate campaign against me is
when i moaned about small power buttons
on the playstation 4 like
but i've been playing games with you
before and your cat has turned off your
playstations
yeah true that's a fair point um all
right so those are our grievances
things that we need to have fixed for
next gen please let us know
your little bug bears in the comments
box below uh come find us on twitter tom
where are you
i am at tamar h on the twitter
that's where the twitter that's like
when people say
oh i'm just hanging out with the
boyfriend
on the twitter jordan where can people
find you they can also find me on
twitter at jmramy
and i'm on the twitter the twitters
that's what my dad calls it
i'm on the twitters at lucy james games
we'll see you next week
bye okay bye
you